Hello, Bay Area Beautiful Nerds. Join me Monday evening November 3rd at the Alamo Draft House in the Mission in San Francisco for a special screening of the brilliant documentary Drop Dead City, followed by a Q&A with me and the filmmakers. If it sounds familiar, Drop Dead City is the movie that Elliot and I covered a few weeks ago as part of our Power Broker series. Now, I don't do that many live events these days, so I hope you'll come hang out with me at the movies,
你好，湾区可爱的书呆子们。欢迎在11月3日星期一晚上加入我，地点在旧金山教会区的阿拉莫德拉夫豪斯（Alamo Draft House），届时将特别放映精彩的纪录片《死亡之城》（Drop Dead City），随后我和制片人将进行问答环节。如果听起来很耳熟，那是因为《死亡之城》就是几周前我和埃利奥特（Elliot）在“权力掮客”（Power Broker）系列节目中讨论过的那部电影。如今我很少参加现场活动，所以我希望你们能来电影院和我一起聚聚，
on Monday, November 3rd. Tickets are cheap. They're under 13 bucks. Sign up for your seat using the event link in the show notes or on our website, 99PI.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last time, reporter Chris Collin left his apartment in San Francisco on a simple errand to pick up his dog, Rosie, from his brother's house. It was a sunny, beautiful.
在11月3日星期一。票价很便宜，不到13美元。请使用节目说明中的活动链接或访问我们的网站 99PI.org 报名预订座位。这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。上期节目中，记者克里斯·科林（Chris Collin）离开他在旧金山的公寓，去他兄弟家接他的狗罗西（Rosie），这本是一件简单的小事。那是一个阳光明媚、美好的
Saturday afternoon as Chris drove down Bayshore Boulevard in his fairly new Ford escape. And I'm going about 40, and all of a sudden, out of nowhere, the car shuts off. The steering locks up. The power brakes die. You can't do anything. And, you know, there's not really emergency brakes like there used to be. So I'm just like rocketing down Bayshore. And up ahead, I see the road sort of bend, and there's like a little. bit of an area where one would fly off. I didn't know what to do. I actually started, like, reaching for the handle, you know, the door handle. Like, am I going to do some, like, Lee Major's style stunt here? Chris did not have to dive out of his moving car, thank God. Instead of flying
周六下午，克里斯开着他那辆相当新的福特翼虎（Ford Escape）行驶在湾岸大道（Bayshore Boulevard）上。当时我车速大约40英里，突然间，毫无征兆地，车子熄火了。方向盘锁死，动力刹车失灵。你什么也做不了。而且，你知道，现在的车不像以前那样有紧急刹车了。所以我当时就像在湾岸大道上飞驰。前方我看到道路有点弯曲，还有一点点可能会冲出路面的区域。我不知道该怎么办。我甚至开始伸手去够车门把手，你知道，车门把手。我在想，我是要在这里上演李·梅杰斯（Lee Majors）式的特技吗？谢天谢地，克里斯最终没有从行驶的车中跳出来。相反，在飞出
off the road, the compact SUV somehow miraculously drifted to a stop. Obviously, the experience was pretty scary. Chris also had no idea what had caused the malfunction. And as he took the car from one mechanic to another and then another, he learned that they couldn't figure out the problem either. But Chris wasn't really worried. He had the confidence of a new car owner protected by a warranty. He was sure that Ford would fix this quickly and he would get on with his life. Easy. So he reached out to the one place designed to help consumers like him with problems just like this, the customer service department. I call Ford headquarters and I'm like, okay, time to start talking about returning this car or whatever you do when it can't be fixed.
路面之前，这辆紧凑型SUV奇迹般地滑行并停了下来。显然，这次经历非常可怕。克里斯也不知道故障的原因。当他把车从一家修理厂送到另一家，又送到第三家时，他发现他们也找不出问题所在。但克里斯并没有太担心。他有着新车主受保修保护的自信。他确信福特会很快修好这辆车，他也能继续正常生活。很简单。于是他联系了那个专门为像他这样遇到此类问题的消费者提供帮助的部门——客户服务部。我给福特总部打电话，我说，好吧，是时候谈谈退车或者在车修不好时该怎么办了。
And that's when they tell me, well, until we can replicate the problem, we can't make good on this warranty. Again and again, Chris called customer service, hoping to reach a human being who would understand his issue and help him solve it. Instead, Chris's life descended into a months-long saga with customer care. He describes this whole experience as, quote, a cretness ordeal. I'm just making these dumb, boring phone calls, waiting on hold, getting transferred, having to type in my zip code again, having to re-explain the problem again. You know, increasingly I find that I'm getting disconnected, the call gets cut off, or I get transferred back to the wrong person. We have all been here, maybe with a car company, or your internet provider, or an airline. You call a customer service line, you get routed, and then rerouted, and then re-routed for hours.
就在那时，他们告诉我，除非我们能复现这个问题，否则我们无法履行保修承诺。克里斯一次又一次地拨打客服电话，希望能联系到一个能理解他的问题并帮助他解决的人。然而，克里斯的生活陷入了一场与客户服务部门长达数月的拉锯战。他将整个经历描述为，引用他的话，“一场令人崩溃的磨难”。我只是在打这些愚蠢、无聊的电话，在等待中被转接，不得不再次输入邮政编码，不得不再次解释问题。你知道，我越来越频繁地遇到电话被挂断、通话中断，或者被转接到错误的人那里。我们都经历过这种情况，也许是和汽车公司，或者是你的互联网供应商，又或者是航空公司。你拨打客服热线，被转来转去，转了几个小时。
The call gets dropped, and after a few minutes. of screaming into the void, you start the whole thing all over again. Or you get a virtual assistant, who, no matter how many times you yell, operator, will not connect you to a real person. And then slowly, your will to fight starts to dissolve. I started talking to people about it. And what they all said to me is, yeah, oh my God, I deal with this all the time. And I just reach a point where I say, fuck it.
电话断了，在对着虚空尖叫了几分钟后，你又得从头开始。或者你遇到了一个虚拟助手，无论你喊多少次“人工服务”，它都不会把你转接给真人。然后慢慢地，你抗争的意志开始瓦解。我开始和别人谈论这件事。他们对我说的是，是的，天哪，我一直都在处理这种情况。我最终只能说，去他的吧。
I'm sorry to go purple on you, Roman, but that is what they. say, and I really feel like that encapsulates something about what's happening to us as a society. You have this parking ticket that you don't want to contest anymore. You have a claim that you can't argue about anymore. And you just say, I'll pay the $30. I'll pay the $90. And I started to see that we are living in a state of fuck it. In the middle of his car ordeal, Chris also started to wonder if the headaches and frustrations we all face when we deal with customer service are all by design.
抱歉对你说了脏话，罗曼，但这就是他们说的，我真的觉得这概括了我们作为一个社会正在发生的事情。你有一张不想再申诉的停车罚单。你有一个无法再争辩的索赔。你只能说，我付那30美元吧，我付那90美元吧。我开始意识到，我们正生活在一种“去他的”状态中。在处理车子问题的过程中，克里斯也开始怀疑，我们处理客户服务时所面临的头痛和挫折是否都是刻意设计的。
And it turns out, yeah, a lot of the times they are. Recently, I spoke with Chris about his latest story for The Atlantic in which he writes about these kinds of obstacles in customer care that drive us all crazy. There's even a name for them. They're called sludge. Sludge is basically the stuff that slows us down. It's friction, it's legalese, it's needless complexity. It's all of these things that don't rise to. the level of, you know, a policy that tells you can't have something. It's a, it's subtler and
事实证明，是的，很多时候确实如此。最近，我和克里斯聊了他为《大西洋月刊》（The Atlantic）撰写的最新报道，他在文中写到了客户服务中那些让我们抓狂的障碍。它们甚至有一个名字，叫“淤泥”（sludge）。“淤泥”基本上就是那些拖慢我们速度的东西。它是摩擦力，是法律术语，是毫无必要的复杂性。所有这些东西都没有上升到“政策规定你不能拥有某样东西”的程度。它更微妙，
more insidious than that, but it deters you from getting what you're owed. And you write that sludge is this term coined by the legal scholar Cass Sunstein and Richard Haler, the economist. And this is the polar opposite of Nudge, which is their research about trying to get you to do things. This is trying to get things shut down, I guess, you know. It's cavernous procedural stuff on forms and questionnaires. It's the administrative hoops that you have to jump through to get basic things done. And when it comes to customer service, it's stuff like endless wait times. Exactly. You can have perfectly good policy, but if folks are discouraged from getting whatever they're owed, then what's the point of the policy? So you went about trying to identify the
更阴险，但它阻止了你获得你应得的东西。你写道，“淤泥”这个词是由法律学者卡斯·桑斯坦（Cass Sunstein）和经济学家理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）创造的。这与他们的研究“助推”（Nudge）截然相反，“助推”是试图引导你去做某事。而“淤泥”则是试图让事情停滞，我想，你知道。它是表格和问卷中深不见底的程序性内容。它是你为了完成基本事项而必须跳过的行政障碍。当涉及到客户服务时，就是像无休止的等待时间这样的东西。没错。你可以有非常好的政策，但如果人们被劝阻不去获取他们应得的东西，那么政策的意义何在？所以你试图找出
various tactics and companies and institutions used to create sludge, the secret art of sludge, so to speak. And to do that, you talk to people in the customer service industry. So who and what did you find that was enlightening for you? Yeah, what I found was a guy. His name is Amas Tanuma. And he sort of became my deep throat. He has been working in the contact center industry or call centers, we sometimes call them, for a couple decades. He started out as a call center worker.
公司和机构用来制造“淤泥”的各种策略，也就是所谓的“淤泥的秘密艺术”。为了做到这一点，你采访了客户服务行业的人。那么你发现了什么对你有启发的人和事？是的，我发现了一个人。他的名字叫阿马斯·塔努马（Amas Tanuma）。他成了我的“深喉”。他在联络中心行业，也就是我们有时所说的呼叫中心，工作了大约二十年。他最初是一名呼叫中心员工。
And he worked his way up to where he was setting them up, overseeing them, managing them, and, you know, around the world, and he starts telling me the tricks that they have in these call centers. And unlike most people in this line of work, he was willing to pull back the curtain and talk about some of the dark secrets of the industry. So let's get into those dark secrets that shape the design of modern customer service. What are some of the components that you were sort of led through by Amos to Numa? Yeah. So first of all, obviously, when you need to call a company, you're not going to get through to a person right away. You're going to wait on hold. We are all familiar with the line. Hold times are longer than it expected or however they
他一路晋升到负责建立、监督和管理它们，你知道，在世界各地，他开始告诉我这些呼叫中心里的伎俩。与这个行业的大多数人不同，他愿意拉开帷幕，谈论一些行业内幕。那么，让我们深入了解那些塑造现代客户服务设计的黑暗秘密吧。阿马斯·塔努马带你了解了哪些组成部分？是的。首先，显然，当你需要给一家公司打电话时，你不会立即联系到人。你得等待。我们都很熟悉那句台词：“等待时间比预期的要长”，或者他们
phrased it. So that is a form of sludge, too, because companies could hire enough call center workers that we don't have to wait on hold as long, but they don't. So that's step number one in creating sludge. You're going to talk to someone who needs to hear every little bit about, you know, who you are, where you live, what your phone number is. They're going to need to transfer you. So it happens at that level. But it also happens above. that. It happens when you are the company and you choose where to locate your customer service. I think we all probably remember that customer service got outsourced and then moved to, usually to places outside the country, where labor is cheaper. And what Amos explained to me is that
措辞的其他方式。所以这也是一种“淤泥”，因为公司本可以雇佣足够的呼叫中心员工，让我们不必等待那么久，但他们没有。所以这是制造“淤泥”的第一步。你需要和一个需要了解你的一切细节的人交谈，比如你是谁、你住在哪里、你的电话号码是多少。他们需要转接你。所以它发生在那个层面。但它也发生在更高层面。当你是一家公司并选择在哪里设立客户服务中心时，它也会发生。我想我们可能都记得客户服务被外包，然后通常被转移到国外劳动力更便宜的地方。阿马斯向我解释说，
one aspect of sludge happens in that location because we have to make long-distance calls to reach those call centers and there are more reliable ways of setting up those calls, I learned, and then there are cheaper ways and those companies usually choose the cheaper ways. So that's another kind of sludge because the call quality is poor.
“淤泥”的一个方面就发生在那个地点，因为我们必须拨打长途电话才能联系到那些呼叫中心，我了解到，建立这些通话有更可靠的方式，也有更便宜的方式，而那些公司通常选择更便宜的方式。所以这是另一种“淤泥”，因为通话质量很差。
You do get disconnected sometimes. And so these are kind of more passive elements of sludge's architecture. Right. So I want to ask you about the front line of this customer service apparatus, the one that we deal with when we sort of encounter sludge, and that's the customer service rep.
你有时确实会掉线。所以这些是“淤泥”架构中比较被动的元素。没错。所以我想问你关于这个客户服务机构的前线，也就是我们遇到“淤泥”时所面对的人，即客户服务代表。
You spoke with Amos and others about these frontline people. Can you just talk about what that role is and how hard it is on them, actually, to deal with this? Yeah, I'm glad you mentioned that because as frustrated as we get with the person on the other end of the call, it is a really, really hard and pretty joyless job as far as I can understand it. I talk to a lot of folks who do it, and what they describe is more like, like a factory floor than an office job. Every aspect of their work is measured. There are all these penalties if they escalate a call too many times.
你和阿马斯以及其他人谈到了这些前线人员。你能谈谈这个角色是什么，以及处理这些事情对他们来说实际上有多困难吗？是的，我很高兴你提到这一点，因为尽管我们对通话另一端的人感到沮丧，但据我所知，这是一份非常、非常困难且毫无乐趣的工作。我和很多做这份工作的人谈过，他们描述的情况更像是工厂车间，而不是办公室工作。他们工作的每一个方面都被衡量。如果他们转接电话次数太多，就会受到各种惩罚。
If they solve too many problems, if they give away too many credits, which is a term of the industry. So, yeah, it's very easy to get frustrated with them, especially when they are talking in this kind of inhuman corporate language. but I think it's a job that puts them in a really impossible spot where basically they're not trying to serve the customer. And a big part of sludge, and this is what I heard from call center workers that I talked to, the big part of sludge is having that person, that humanity, trained out of you. Amos, Tanuma, said they're training you into being an algorithm. Because people are naturally empathetic.
如果他们解决了太多问题，如果他们发放了太多信用额度（这是行业术语），也会受到惩罚。所以，是的，很容易对他们感到沮丧，尤其是当他们用这种非人的企业语言说话时。但我认为这份工作把他们置于一个非常不可能的境地，基本上他们不是在试图服务客户。而“淤泥”的一大部分，这是我从我交谈过的呼叫中心员工那里听到的，就是让那个人，那种人性，从你身上被训练掉。阿马斯·塔努马说，他们正在把你训练成一个算法。因为人天生是有同理心的。
And as Amos told me, that doesn't serve. of the bottom line. They have to train that out of you very quickly. Otherwise, those call center workers are just going to be giving away what you're entitled to, and that doesn't help them. And one thing that kind of encapsulates the problem with these call centers is something you mentioned about your own experience that I think we probably all experienced. And that's dropped calls and getting disconnected when you get transferred and all these little, you know, accidents, if you will. And you say, Amas, kind of explain what was really happening here. Yeah, I start calling him and I'm Like, Amas, is this really accidental?
正如阿马斯告诉我的，这不利于底线。他们必须非常快地把你身上的那种人性训练掉。否则，那些呼叫中心员工只会把你们应得的东西给出去，这对他们没有帮助。有一件事概括了这些呼叫中心的问题，就是你提到的关于你自己的经历，我想我们可能都经历过。那就是掉线，以及当你被转接时通话中断，所有这些小小的，如果你愿意的话，意外。你说，阿马斯解释了这里到底发生了什么。是的，我开始打电话给他，我说，阿马斯，这真的是意外吗？
It doesn't seem like it. And he just laughs. He's like, of course it's on purpose. You know, there are all these tricks. And one is these agents have something called an average handle time. What's your average length of your phone call, basically? They get penalized all the time. I mean, going to the bathroom, they measure the length of how long they're away from their headsets.
看起来不像。他只是笑了笑。他说，当然是故意的。你知道，有各种各样的伎俩。其中之一是这些代理人有一个所谓的“平均处理时间”。基本上就是你通话的平均时长。他们一直受到惩罚。我的意思是，去洗手间，他们会测量他们离开耳机的时间。
So they are really afraid of getting penalized. If their handle time starts creeping up, what's an easy way to bring your average down? Hang up very quickly. So that's one common thing. So, yeah, those hang-ups are often on purpose. And is this the kind of thing where it's explicitly stated somewhere in company policy that like a rep has to cut off a collar after five minutes? Or is it just a corporation incentivizing various departments to cut corners and cut costs
所以他们真的很害怕受到惩罚。如果他们的处理时间开始增加，缩短平均时间的一个简单方法是什么？很快挂断电话。所以这是一个常见的事情。所以，是的，那些挂断电话通常是故意的。这是公司政策中明确规定的吗，比如代表必须在五分钟后切断通话？还是说这只是公司激励各个部门削减开支和成本，
without any individuals actually conspiring? It is hard to prove. It's insidious. It's subtle. These organizations are, the architecture of them is cellular. So, you know, if you are the person answering the phone, you don't know what the order was from, you know, two notches above you. You're just doing what's been asked of you. So a lot of people aren't aware that they are perpetuating sludge.
而没有任何个人在真正密谋？这很难证明。它是阴险的，微妙的。这些组织，它们的架构是细胞状的。所以，你知道，如果你是接电话的人，你不知道你上面两级下达的命令是什么。你只是在做被要求做的事情。所以很多人并没有意识到他们正在延续“淤泥”。
At the top, I don't think they say, let's do bad service. I think they just say, we need to bring these numbers, you know, to this place. Please make that happen. And that trickles down. So it doesn't have to be all deliberate, but it's still happening. And I always think about George Carlin line. You don't need a formal conspiracy when interests align. The interest is for us to give up and to walk away before we get what we're owed.
在顶层，我不认为他们会说，让我们提供糟糕的服务。我想他们只是说，我们需要把这些数字带到这个位置。请实现它。然后这会向下渗透。所以它不一定是蓄意的，但它确实在发生。我总是想起乔治·卡林（George Carlin）的一句话：当利益一致时，你不需要正式的阴谋。利益在于让我们放弃，并在我们得到应得的东西之前走开。
I love that George Carlin quote so much. And it makes me wonder, like, conspiracy or not, you know, for the companies that use sludge tactics on their customers, like hanging up on them, are there actual consequences? Like, is there accountability? Yeah. So you have groups like the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau that's gone after Toyota for Toyota set up this hotline to give you a refund on something. And it was a dead-end hotline. You couldn't get through. And ProPublica a couple years ago showed that Cigna had saved millions of dollars by rejecting claims without having doctors read them, knowing that a limited number of customers would go through the process of appeal. Now, Cigna has since pushed back. on that I'm obliged to say. But it's that kind of thing where they know that you are just going to give up or they set up a hotline where you literally can't get through to a person because they're trying to get you to go online. They want you to deal with their website rather than a person on the other end of the phone. You would think that sludge is actually bad for business in the
我非常喜欢乔治·卡林的这句话。这让我怀疑，无论是否有阴谋，你知道，对于那些对客户使用“淤泥”策略的公司，比如挂断电话，会有实际的后果吗？比如，有问责制吗？是的。所以你有像消费者金融保护局（Consumer Financial Protection Bureau）这样的组织，他们起诉了丰田，因为丰田设立了这条热线来给你退款。但那是一条死胡同热线。你根本打不通。几年前，ProPublica报道称，信诺（Cigna）通过在没有医生阅读的情况下拒绝索赔，节省了数百万美元，因为他们知道只有有限数量的客户会走上诉程序。现在，信诺已经对此进行了反驳。我必须说明这一点。但就是那种情况，他们知道你只会放弃，或者他们设立了一条你根本无法联系到人的热线，因为他们想让你上网。他们希望你处理他们的网站，而不是电话另一端的人。你可能会认为“淤泥”实际上对生意不利，
long run, that companies would worry about making things like too sludgy and that would backfire and customers would just take their business elsewhere. Could you talk about the gamble that companies are willing to take in making this calculation? Yeah, that's a great question, and I wonder that throughout my saga, why is this helping them for me to be this frustrated? Surely this is bad for business. It pays off. It's a calculation they're making. Maybe it doesn't pay off in the long run, but these CEOs, their tenure is shorter than ever, so they are not going for the long-term health of their company, they're going for short-term gains, just growing the company as fast as possible. It's fascinating me how the whole system has sort of evolved to lead to sludge. Like, a CEO's
从长远来看，公司会担心把事情搞得太“淤泥化”，这会适得其反，客户会把生意带到别处。你能谈谈公司在做出这种计算时愿意承担的赌博吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题，我在整个磨难中也一直在想，我这么沮丧对他们有什么帮助？这肯定对生意不利。它有回报。这是他们正在做的计算。也许从长远来看它没有回报，但这些CEO的任期比以往任何时候都短，所以他们追求的不是公司的长期健康，而是短期收益，尽可能快地发展公司。整个系统是如何演变成导致“淤泥”的，这让我着迷。比如，CEO的
tenure is short, maybe shorter than ever, and they're paid more in stock prices than salary. So their incentive is to save the company as much money as possible in the quarter that they're in and increase share prices fast. So they want immediate results, more than they're worried about keeping a long-term customer satisfied because of fuck about that person. Like, they're not providing more shareholder value at all. And you can then see how everything in the system leads to sludgy, frustrating experiences, the kind that we've all been through. Yeah, no, that's totally right. It's the incentive structure. And so that means getting new customers rather than tending to the existing ones. And we can see that. We feel that. It's really easy
任期很短，也许比以往任何时候都短，而且他们拿到的股票价格比工资多。所以他们的动机是在他们任职的季度内尽可能多地为公司省钱，并快速提高股价。所以他们想要立竿见影的结果，而不是担心保持长期客户的满意度，因为“去他的”那个人。就像，他们根本没有提供更多的股东价值。然后你就可以看到系统中的一切是如何导致“淤泥”般的、令人沮丧的体验的，也就是我们都经历过的那种。是的，不，那完全正确。这就是激励结构。这意味着获取新客户而不是照顾现有客户。我们可以看到这一点。我们感觉到了。这真的很容易
to sign up for a new service. It's really easy to pay a company money. You don't ever have to wait on hold to do that. Those wheels are perfectly well greased. The problem is when you have a problem as an existing customer. So for those reasons, you start to see it trickle down into the call centers. You know, they need to hit their numbers. And when they don't do that, then that's when they have to start pulling whatever levers they have. But it's also our fault.
注册一项新服务。给公司付钱真的很容易。你永远不需要为了做这件事而等待。那些轮子润滑得非常好。问题在于当你作为现有客户遇到问题时。所以由于这些原因，你开始看到它渗透到呼叫中心。你知道，他们需要达到他们的数字。当他们做不到时，那就是他们必须开始拉动他们所拥有的任何杠杆的时候。但这也是我们的错。
That's something that my source Amos Tanuma pointed out. He said, look, yes, sludge is out there. it's insidious, but we as consumers and customers have a responsibility, too. He said, one of the most hated airlines in this country, he named it, I won't say it, but I think if you live in the United States of America, you can probably figure out what it is. People despise this airline, and they get back on those planes every time as soon as the price is right. So we are not disciplined consumers. As a Moss told me, if we want to have an impact, if we want to try and move the needle in some way, we need to start by, you know, paying attention to who we support and who we don't.
这是我的消息来源阿马斯·塔努马指出的。他说，看，是的，“淤泥”就在那里，它是阴险的，但我们作为消费者和客户也有责任。他说，这个国家最令人讨厌的航空公司之一，他点名了，我不会说出来，但我想如果你住在美国，你可能能猜出它是哪一家。人们鄙视这家航空公司，但只要价格合适，他们每次都会重新坐上那些飞机。所以我们不是有纪律的消费者。正如阿马斯告诉我的，如果我们想产生影响，如果我们想尝试以某种方式推动改变，我们需要从关注我们支持谁和不支持谁开始。
I don't know. I mean, like, I get that there's a part of the system that involves me, but to say, like, it's my responsibility to unhook myself from the system so that it breaks seems like a little disingenuous. Definitely. Like, they put me here. Like, I was put here by them, not me. That's right. Yeah. Yeah, I know. I know. But I digress. Okay. I want to ask you about some of the more dangerous kinds of sludge. Like, I mean, you mentioned that, you know, you had to deal with your car problem, but you're a journalist. You work at home a lot. You have some free time. You can navigate this a bit differently than other folks. But there are things like changes to Medicaid, which are introducing new sludge into the system, like having work requirements, which are this dark and cynical form of sludge. Like the system is getting more oriented, so they have to prove that you deserve these benefits instead of getting them more automatically. And these roadblocks to crucial public services can have really harmful consequences.
我不知道。我的意思是，我明白系统的一部分涉及我，但说“我有责任将自己从系统中解脱出来，以便它崩溃”似乎有点虚伪。当然。就像，他们把我放在这里。我是被他们放在这里的，不是我自己。没错。是的。是的，我知道。我知道。但我离题了。好的。我想问你一些更危险的“淤泥”。比如，我的意思是，你提到你不得不处理你的汽车问题，但你是一名记者。你经常在家工作。你有空闲时间。你可以以不同于其他人的方式处理这个问题。但还有一些事情，比如医疗补助（Medicaid）的变化，正在将新的“淤泥”引入系统，比如有工作要求，这是这种黑暗和愤世嫉俗的“淤泥”形式。就像系统变得更加导向，所以他们必须证明你理应获得这些福利，而不是自动获得它们。而这些对关键公共服务的阻碍可能会产生非常有害的后果。
Could you talk about the dangers of sludge when it comes to our society? Yeah, I mean, I had the privilege of fighting over something as small as a car. I mean, it was annoying, but it was just a car. There are people who are getting screwed out of insurance, out of SNAP benefits, out of all kinds of, benefits they're entitled to and that have like you say real world intense consequences and you see it all the time you see it in the big beautiful bill there are benefits that we are entitled to and we are being prevented from accessing them and the consequences are huge it has to do with our health has to do that with uh you know whether our kids get the benefits or get food on the table
你能谈谈“淤泥”在社会方面的危险吗？是的，我的意思是，我有幸为像汽车这样的小事而战。我的意思是，这很烦人，但这只是一辆车。有些人因为保险、SNAP福利，以及各种他们有权获得的福利而被坑，而且正如你所说，这有现实世界中强烈的后果，你一直都能看到。你在那份宏大的法案中看到，有些福利是我们有权获得的，但我们被阻止获取它们，后果是巨大的。这与我们的健康有关，与我们的孩子是否获得福利或餐桌上是否有食物有关。
into some of the weird history of sludge and talk about ways to survive the sluggiest parts of modern day customer service. I'm back with Chris Collin. And I want to talk a little bit about some of sludge's weird past because you discovered that sludge has a quirky historical ancestor.
进入“淤泥”的一些奇怪历史，并谈谈在现代客户服务最“淤泥”的部分中生存的方法。我回到了克里斯·科林身边。我想谈谈“淤泥”的一些奇怪过去，因为你发现“淤泥”有一个古怪的历史祖先。
Yeah, on my hold times when I was waiting there going crazy. I would, of course, you know, play on my phone, search for things on Google. And I started reading this field manual for sabotage that was created in the early 40s that our government made and distributed to citizens in Nazi occupied Europe. And it's an awesome document.
是的，在我等待时，我快疯了。我当然会，你知道，玩我的手机，在谷歌上搜索东西。我开始阅读一份由政府在40年代初创建并分发给纳粹占领下的欧洲公民的破坏手册。这是一份很棒的文件。
One of the best documents our government has ever created. And you can get it online. It's very easy to find because it's been declassified. And it's full of these dumb little ideas for how you can sabotage whoever's keeping you down. In their case, the Nazis. But it's not taking up arms. It's weaponizing incompetence. So lose your tools.
这是我们政府有史以来创造的最好的文件之一。你可以在网上找到它。它很容易找到，因为它已经被解密了。它充满了关于你如何破坏任何压迫你的人的愚蠢小点子。在他们的情况下，是纳粹。但它不是拿起武器。它是将无能武器化。所以弄丢你的工具。
In meetings, bring up needless topics to discuss. Give people the wrong directions. Like, make them go the long way. So if you're in an occupied country, these are just all the things you can do as a citizen to just slow down the gears of the occupier. Absolutely. And as I read it, I was thinking, oh my God, this is what they are doing to us. This is sludge in a nutshell. It's all of these silly little ways to sort of slow us down and impede our progress. So that's kind of the ghost of sludge past, but I also wonder about the ghost of sludge future. So you're from San Francisco. I drive through San Francisco all the time. And all the billboards I see are about AI agents helping me through customer service. But actually, they're trying to sell AI agents to companies to help me through customer service.
在会议中，提出不必要的议题来讨论。给人们错误的指示。比如，让他们走远路。所以如果你在一个被占领的国家，这些都是你可以作为一个公民做的所有事情，只是为了减慢占领者的齿轮。绝对是这样。当我读到它时，我在想，天哪，这就是他们对我们做的事情。这就是“淤泥”的缩影。所有这些愚蠢的小方法，旨在减慢我们的速度并阻碍我们的进步。所以这就是“淤泥”过去的幽灵，但我也想知道“淤泥”未来的幽灵。所以你是旧金山人。我一直开车经过旧金山。我看到的所有广告牌都是关于AI代理帮助我处理客户服务。但实际上，他们是在试图向公司推销AI代理来帮助我处理客户服务。
How do you anticipate AI adding to or maybe taking away from the sludge? I don't want to be too cynical out of the gate. I was afraid you were going to ask this. It's not going to be good. Yeah, no. Now, AI is about to make things way, way worse. Obviously, we encounter AI already when we call customer service, but they are about to dump much more on us.
你如何预见AI会增加还是减少“淤泥”？我不想一开始就太愤世嫉俗。我怕你会问这个。这不会是好事。是的，不。现在，AI即将让事情变得更糟。显然，当我们拨打客户服务时，我们已经遇到了AI，但他们即将向我们倾倒更多。
And this actually goes back to COVID. COVID, as you'll recall, had us all locked in. We weren't going out, and so we had to do a lot more remote customer service. And companies had to hire AI to field those calls. And after the pandemics are to let up, and companies could sort of reappraise their systems, they took a look and they asked customers, you know, basically, how was that for you? And we all said the same thing. That sucked. That was terrible. Please don't make us talk to AI anymore. We don't like it. It was unambiguous. And what companies heard was, so you tolerated
这实际上可以追溯到新冠疫情。正如你所记得的，新冠疫情让我们都被锁在家里。我们没有出去，所以我们不得不做更多的远程客户服务。公司不得不雇佣AI来处理这些电话。疫情开始缓解后，公司可以重新评估他们的系统，他们看了一眼，问客户，你知道，基本上，这对你来说怎么样？我们都说了同样的话。那糟透了。那太可怕了。请不要再让我们和AI说话了。我们不喜欢它。这是明确无误的。而公司听到的是，所以你忍受了
it? So ever since then, they took away this kind of deranged lesson, which is that we may not like dealing with AI, but we're willing to suck it up. And so ever since then, the race has been on to find new ways to bring AI to customer service. And this is the ultimate, like, dehumanization of the customer service system. Yeah. Because you're, they're just reading your syllables and translating into something and then, you know, putting phonemes back at you. And it's, it's not an actual conversation. That's right.
它？所以从那时起，他们吸取了这种疯狂的教训，那就是我们可能不喜欢和AI打交道，但我们愿意忍受。所以从那时起，寻找将AI引入客户服务的新方法的竞赛就开始了。这是客户服务系统最终的“去人性化”。是的。因为你，他们只是在读取你的音节并翻译成某种东西，然后，你知道，把音素回馈给你。这不是真正的对话。没错。
And to be fair, there are things AI is good at. Of course. There are ways that it can solve problems more efficiently than human call center agents can do. But by and large, it drives us crazy, and that's a big part of sludge architecture is us going crazy. I mean, I began doing, like, when I get a, you know, when I get like a sort of phone thing, I just began saying operator into the thing or hitting zero all the time. Are there like, what are some guerrilla tactics of just getting through the sludge if they still work at all? I'm sorry to say those days are behind us. It used to be that you could press zero or you could say operator or agent or speak uninterested.
公平地说，AI确实有擅长的事情。当然。在某些方面，它可以比人类呼叫中心代理更有效地解决问题。但总的来说，它让我们抓狂，而“淤泥”架构的一大部分就是让我们抓狂。我的意思是，我开始做，比如，当我得到一个，你知道，当我得到某种电话东西时，我只是开始对着那个东西说“人工服务”或者一直按零。有没有，比如，如果它们仍然有效的话，有没有什么突破“淤泥”的游击战术？我很遗憾地说，那些日子已经过去了。过去你可以按零，或者你可以说“人工服务”或“代理”或说得含糊不清，
intelligibly, and they would eventually connect you, but they have gotten wise to that stuff. They want to make you wait on hold as long as you can, so eventually you get frustrated, and then you use their web portal, which may or may not work. Yeah. So a few weeks ago, before my twins had to go to college, I had to get them their California real ID. And I sent in some of the proof of address and all the different forms ahead of time. And we decided to go first thing when they opened in the morning so that we could get into the queue properly. I didn't set an appointment.
他们最终会把你转接，但他们已经对这些东西变聪明了。他们想让你尽可能长时间地等待，这样你最终会感到沮丧，然后你就会使用他们的网络门户，这可能有效也可能无效。是的。所以几周前，在我的双胞胎上大学之前，我必须为他们办理加州真实身份证（Real ID）。我提前寄出了一些地址证明和所有不同的表格。我们决定在他们早上开门时第一时间去，这样我们就能正确地进入队列。我没有预约。
We just went really early in the morning. And when you go in, you get this kind of deli-style number, like D-25 and, you know, G-27. And it doesn't go exactly in order. Like, you know that your number is coming up, but because they have these different letters, you know, it's a little opaque and they have some room to make decisions on the fly based on, like, I don't know how important your problem is with the DMV. Yeah. But the point is, I was, like, struck by how things seemed so fair and just transparent enough that no one gets upset about it because we're. all moving forward in the system. And I thought it was kind of this brilliant experience. Like, at the California DMV of all places, like that used to be Exhibit A of sludge. And they seemed to
我们只是去得很早。当你进去时，你会得到这种熟食店风格的号码，比如D-25和，你知道，G-27。它并不完全按顺序进行。比如，你知道你的号码快到了，但因为他们有这些不同的字母，你知道，它有点不透明，他们有一些空间可以根据，比如，我不知道你在DMV的问题有多重要，来即时做出决定。是的。但重点是，我被那种看起来如此公平且足够透明的事情所打动，以至于没有人对此感到不安，因为我们都在系统中前进。我觉得这是一种非常精彩的体验。就像，在加州DMV这样的地方，那曾经是“淤泥”的典型案例。而他们似乎
have really overcome this horrible reputation. Yeah, I agree. I think the DMV has gotten its act together. I think they got tired of being the butt of jokes. I suspect they did something called a sludge audit, which is what some folks who are battling the sludge phenomenon are calling for. Just having this be a normal part of businesses. and of government agencies, do a sludge audit. Take a look at your systems and see, are they sludgy? Can they be made more efficient? Can they be made less opaque?
真的克服了这种可怕的声誉。是的，我同意。我认为DMV已经把事情处理好了。我想他们厌倦了成为笑柄。我怀疑他们做了一件叫做“淤泥审计”的事情，这就是一些正在与“淤泥”现象作斗争的人所呼吁的。让这成为企业和政府机构的正常部分，进行“淤泥审计”。看看你的系统，看看它们是否“淤泥化”了？它们能变得更有效率吗？它们能变得不那么不透明吗？
Yeah, I think that's an example of, you know, doing it right. So your article is really fun because it's fun to find someone who is experienced in the same misery as you are, even though the subject of sludge is pretty dreary. But one of the things in your article that made my heart leap was you describing admin night, which is sort for like administrative night. And it's this thing that you came up with to deal with the source. sludge of the world. Could you describe Admin Night? Yes, thank you. I love Admin Night. I love talking about Admin Night. I am now going to proselytize about it. Please. A few years ago, I realized that
是的，我认为这是一个做对事情的例子。所以你的文章真的很有趣，因为找到一个和你经历同样痛苦的人很有趣，尽管“淤泥”这个主题相当沉闷。但你文章中让我心跳加速的一件事是你描述了“行政之夜”（admin night），这是行政之夜的缩写。这是你想出来的处理世界上“淤泥”的东西。你能描述一下“行政之夜”吗？是的，谢谢。我喜欢“行政之夜”。我喜欢谈论“行政之夜”。我现在要为此传教了。请。几年前，我意识到
among my friends, there was this new genre of excuse popping up into our discourse about why you couldn't hang out on Thursday night, like a time when we'd normally go get a beer or whatever. I started hearing from them and from myself, uh, uh, I, you know, I'd love to, but I got to deal. with this stupid insurance thing or I've got to fill out this forum for my kid's school or I've got to catch up on bills or it was all familiar normal sort of domestic responsibilities but there's just so much of it all of a sudden it felt like we were just overwhelmed in a new way at a new level and I saw it kind of atomizing us so I fired off an email to a bunch of friends and neighbors And I said, come over next Tuesday night, bring a six-pack, bring a big pile of whatever paperwork has been weighing on you or whatever stupid bureaucratic thing you've got to deal with.
在我的朋友中，出现了一种新的借口流派，出现在我们关于为什么你周四晚上不能出来玩的讨论中，比如我们通常会去喝啤酒的时间。我开始从他们那里，也从我自己那里听到，呃，呃，我，你知道，我很想去，但我得处理这个愚蠢的保险问题，或者我得为我孩子的学校填这张表格，或者我得补上账单，或者这都是熟悉的、正常的家庭责任，但突然之间太多了。感觉我们以一种新的方式、在一个新的层面上被淹没了。我看到它有点把我们原子化了。所以我给一群朋友和邻居发了一封电子邮件，我说，下周二晚上过来，带上一箱啤酒，带上一大堆压在你身上的文书工作，或者任何你必须处理的愚蠢的官僚主义事情。
And we're going to do it together. And so that became this thing that I call admin night. So friends come over and we do admin together. You talk for five minutes, you know, chit-chat, and then you put your heads down and you power through whatever stuff you've got to do for about 20 minutes. you take a break you hang out some more have a drink have some snacks and you just do this for a couple hours and at the end we all go around the horn and each person names some dumb little thing that they checked off their list and we all cheer and it's awesome it sounds like a really um nerdy thing it doesn't sound like a kind of like the kind of party you might picture when you think of parties but it's
我们要一起做。所以这就成了我所说的“行政之夜”。所以朋友们过来，我们一起做行政工作。你聊五分钟，你知道，闲聊，然后你低下头，全力以赴处理你必须做的任何事情，大约20分钟。你休息一下，再聚聚，喝点东西，吃点零食，你就这样做几个小时。最后，我们轮流转一圈，每个人说出他们从清单上勾掉的一件愚蠢的小事，我们都欢呼，这太棒了。这听起来像是一个非常，嗯，书呆子的事情。这听起来不像你想到派对时可能会想象的那种派对，但它
kind of cool i love it i love it it actually made me so hopeful and amongst all this that i was Oh my God. Maybe we could get this. Admin night, if that came out of this, like your research into sludge, I mean, that would be just beautiful. Thank you. Because that's what it is. It's like it's the doing it alone, feeling crazy. It's also just like the energy to do stuff, just to respond to these things and just like, it's just like the fact, I mean, you're just, you're turning a sludge into nudge. It's pretty great. I also think part of the fun is just daylighting sludge. By having a thing called Admonite, by acknowledging that we are all drowning in this stupid stuff, that alone feels good. That alone is worth something, and it's part of the fight against fuck it.
很酷，我喜欢它，我喜欢它。它实际上让我充满了希望，在所有这些之中，我当时想，天哪。也许我们可以做到这一点。“行政之夜”，如果这是从你的“淤泥”研究中产生的，我的意思是，那将是美丽的。谢谢。因为这就是它。就像独自做这件事，感觉很疯狂。这也就像做事的能量，只是为了回应这些事情，只是，这就像事实，我的意思是，你只是，你正在把“淤泥”变成“助推”。这很棒。我也认为乐趣的一部分只是让“淤泥”见光。通过有一个叫“行政之夜”的东西，通过承认我们都淹没在这些愚蠢的东西中，仅此一点就感觉很好。仅此一点就值得一些东西，它是对抗“去他的”斗争的一部分。
Yeah, yeah. So let's close the loop on your Ford saga. So what ended up happening after you sort of like hit their sludge and then had to navigate it for months on end? I'll tell you what didn't happen. I didn't turn into the guy. read about in Utah who got so frustrated with his car situation that he crashed his Subaru through the front door of a dealership. I didn't do that. I'm glad. I'm pleased to say. After, I think it was
是的，是的。所以让我们结束你的福特传奇。在你遇到他们的“淤泥”并不得不处理它几个月后，最终发生了什么？我会告诉你什么没有发生。我没有变成我在犹他州读到的那个家伙，他因为车子的情况太沮丧，以至于他开着他的斯巴鲁撞进了经销商的前门。我没有那样做。我很高兴。我很高兴地说。在，我想是
a little over 100 days, but eventually I did talk to someone who began the process of buying back the car. And ultimately, that's what happened. They handed me a check. I surrendered my broken car. And then the crazy thing is they had told me they might resell it. And suddenly I was in the grips of a ethical dilemma all over again. Is this car going to get sold to someone else? Are they going to disclose what's wrong with it? I don't have a lot of faith that they will do so given all the stuff I've seen up to this point. And they couldn't really tell me. But the article came out. And since then, some readers have taken it upon themselves to do some research. I got the Atlantic to publish the VIN of my car in the article because I wanted, I was so worried that, you know,
100多天后，但我最终确实和某人谈过了，他开始了回购汽车的过程。最终，这就是发生的事情。他们给了我一张支票。我交出了我那辆坏掉的车。然后疯狂的事情是他们告诉我他们可能会转售它。突然间，我又陷入了道德困境。这辆车会卖给别人吗？他们会披露它有什么问题吗？鉴于我到目前为止看到的所有事情，我不太相信他们会这样做。他们真的不能告诉我。但文章发表了。从那以后，一些读者自发地做了一些研究。我让《大西洋月刊》在文章中发布了我车的VIN码，因为我想要，我太担心了，你知道，
some poor schmuck is going to start driving this dump car. And someone looked up the van. They found the car. I think it's in Kansas. I need to do a little more reporting. But I think someone out there is now driving this car, and I hope that they got it fixed. Wow. So it's like operational in Kansas, not sitting on a lot somewhere.
某个可怜的傻瓜会开始开这辆垃圾车。有人查了VIN码。他们找到了那辆车。我想它在堪萨斯州。我需要做更多的报道。但我认为外面有人现在正在开这辆车，我希望他们把它修好了。哇。所以它在堪萨斯州运行，而不是停在某个停车场。
As far as I can tell at this point. Wow. Well, I'm sorry for your struggle in this whole thing, but I am very happy that you wrote about it and talked us through sludge. because just the act of identifying and putting words around this thing that we all feel is just this great public service that I appreciate. And thanks so much for being on the show again and talk with me at a fun time. No, I did too. Thank you for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson and edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Our executive producer is Kathy 2.
据我目前所知。哇。好吧，我很抱歉你在整件事中的挣扎，但我很高兴你写了它并向我们解释了“淤泥”。因为仅仅是识别并用语言描述我们都感受到的这种东西的行为，就是我所欣赏的这项伟大的公共服务。非常感谢你再次来到节目中并与我进行了一次有趣的谈话。不，我也一样。谢谢你邀请我。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由Swan Real和乔治·兰福德（George Langford）创作。我们的执行制片人是凯西·图（Kathy Tu）。
Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of the visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky, as well as. from a Discord server, and you can find all of our past episodes at 99PI.org.
我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barubei）、杰森·德里昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉舍马顿（Lashemadon）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）和我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是Serious XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北六个街区，在潘多拉大楼（Pandora building）。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在Blue Sky上找到我们，以及从我们的Discord服务器，你可以在99PI.org找到我们过去所有的剧集。
All of our representatives are currently busy. Please stay on the line, and your call will be answered by the next available representative. The estimated hold time is currently less than 96 minutes. Thank you for your patience. I'm going to be able to be. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们所有的客服代表目前都很忙。请保持在线，您的电话将由下一位空闲的代表接听。预计等待时间目前少于96分钟。感谢您的耐心等待。我将能够。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。